[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales de la tnt
voici les titres de l'actualité la
chasse aux véhicules diesel les plus
polluants s'organise un peu partout en
france
la ville de bordeaux réfléchit à les
exclure de son centre ville
reportage de la chaîne télé 7 la cheffe
du groupe sud ouest à suivre dès le
début de cette édition nous rendrons
martinique plus de liberté et moins de
restrictions il est possible depuis une
dizaine de jours de se rendre sur l'île
sans motif impérieux
une bonne nouvelle pour l'économie
locale moulieras la chaîne via atv sur
place le cinéma d confiner les tournages
se multiplient eh oui à toulouse un
nouveau studio vient d'ouvrir le décor
un avion conçu à taille réelle
c'est un tour du cockpit que nous vous
proposons dans ce journal avec via
occitanie et puis enfin devons nous vous
emmènerons en haut de l'église de la
couture au moment des travaux ont débuté
sur la toiture de l'édifice des travaux
en images fournies par nos partenaires
de via lmtv sarthe
après paris lyon et grenoble s autour de
bordeaux d'instaurer une zone à faible
émission ce dispositif qui pourraient se
multiplier partout en france dans les
prochaines années permet d'interdire de
circulation les véhicules les plus
polluants des centres-villes
l'agglomération bordelaise n'a pas
encore adopté ce type de législation
mais pourrait le faire d'ici la fin de
l'année
les associations d'automobilistes s'y
oppose et dénoncent une discrimination
un reportage à bordeaux de francs
poireau pour la rédaction de télé 7
achète du groupe sud ouest
la circulation des véhicules diesel les
plus anciens se rappellent interdite sur
les 14 communes de l'agglomération
bordelaise située à l'intérieur de la
rocade en 2022
la métropole étudient cette question
dans ses tiroirs la mise en place d'une
c'est des feux zones de faibles
émissions pour l'année prochaine cela
signifie que certains véhicules
notamment les diesel dont la
construction remonte avant 2006 ne
pourront plus circuler sur cette zone
la loi impose aux agglomérations de plus
de cent cinquante mille habitants de
mettre en place et des feux à partir de
celle de bordeaux souhaite l'anticiper
pour l'automobile club du sud ouest
cette mesure ne fait pas preuve justice
sociale son président parle de zones à
fortes exclusion rouler dans des
voitures des gens forcément qui n'ont
pas les moyens de s'acheter un véhicule
neuf donc c'est une ségrégation et faire
avec cette population
selon cette association c'est à des feux
pourrait exclure un grand nombre
d'automobiles de l'agglomération
bordelaise entra rocade avec
l'élargissement des mesures restrictives
concernant les véhicules polluants sept
véhicules sur dix ne pourrait plus
circuler en ville d'ici 2025 selon elle
pour claude une biche et vice présidente
en charge de ce dossier à la métropole
et première adjointe au maire de
bordeaux la mise en place d'une et des
feux doit s'accompagner d'une stratégie
de report modal vers les transports en
commun mais pas seulement paris a
grandement communiqué ces derniers temps
sur le dispositif d'accompagnement on
voit bien que des ménages très modestes
en fait ont accès à des dispositifs
supplémentaires de microcrédit qui le
peuvent leur permettre
de s'adapter à cette situation pour
acheter une voiture à 15000 euros
on va leur proposer un micro micro
crédit a admis l'autre au nom c'est pas
du tout dans le rapport une concertation
auprès des maires des communes
concernées par cet effet été lancé par
bordeaux métropole ils auront la charge
de décliner dans leur ville cette règle
d'interdiction de circulation des
véhicules les plus anciens une
concertation des habitants devrait avoir
lieu prochainement
si jamais cette z et feu ne fait pas
l'unanimité au sein de la métropole la
ville de bordeaux partira seul sur ce
dossier fin 2021 les zones concernées
seraient alors situé à l'intérieur des
boulevards et sur une partie de la rive
droite bordelaise
une bonne nouvelle pour l'économie
martiniquaise il en est fini désormais
des motifs impérieux pour voyager entre
l'île et le continent
les passagers et notamment les touristes
attendait cette nouvelle étape avec
impatience les premiers gros porteurs
sont arrivés dès le 9 juin à l'aéroport
martinique aimé césaire un soulagement
pour les commerçants aussi un reportage
en martinique de johan charpentier titi
et de marlène mecque pour la chaîne via
atterri sur place les premiers passagers
exempts de motifs impérieux pour
rejoindre la martinique en provenance de
paris foulent le sol de l'aéroport aimé
césaire et ils l'attendaient depuis
longtemps on a passé un hiver à espérer
espérer et puis on a appris à 20 jours
que à partir du 9
il y avait plus de motifs impérieux j'ai
attendu cette date pour être plus
sereins qu'ils aient voyagé plus en plus
aisément satisfaction partagée par les
commerces de l'aéroport
cette nouvelle étape annonce pour eux
des lendemains plus joyeux aujourd'hui
on sent qu'ils aient un petit peu plus
de mouvement sur l'aéroport on voit du
monde qui circule c'est ça ça fait
plaisir parce qu'on attend nos clients
avec impatience on s'est préparé deux
semaines et en se coupant toute l'année
on sait que chaque année on a une forte
période là elle tombe au mois de juin
une période normalement
c'est plutôt x plutôt calmes pour nous à
l'extérieur l' enthousiasme n'est pas
vraiment de mise pour ce chauffeur de
taxi
hors de question de crier victoire trop
vite là on voit beaucoup déjà arrivé
mais c'est pas encore ça
donc je pense qu'il faudra dans une
cheminée +1 pour que ça redémarre dès
fois on vient on passera journée on ne
travaille pas les restrictions de vols
vers et en provenance de paris ont
bousculé les prévisions des différents
acteurs et s'ils sont satisfaits de la
levée des motifs impérieux le risque
d'une nouvelle vague épidémique reste
dans tous les esprits et l'accélération
du déconfinement décidé cette semaine
par le gouvernement profite évidemment
au monde culturel à toulouse jusqu'à ce
dimanche est organisé le festival en
plein air
rio loco l'un des premiers à pouvoir se
tenir en europe
là aussi le retour sur scène est un ouf
de soulagement poussé par tout les
organisateurs les artistes et les
visiteurs
cette édition 2021 consacrée à l'afrique
est évidemment unique du fait des
contraintes sanitaires
la jauge a été notamment réduite à trois
mille spectateurs par jour les aurait
avancé et les spectateurs doivent rester
assis pendant les concerts malgré cela
le plaisir est au rendez vous écoutez à
ce propos festivaliers des artistes au
micro de manon aussi de nos partenaires
de la dépêche sur place c'est notamment
le fameux temps des maliens amadou et
mariam qui a assuré le show pour
l'ouverture du festival
c'est le temps d'avoir un peu de musique
en live d'avoir un peu de son côté fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas
ce n'est pas qu'on doit écouter
n'importe quoi mais on avait indiqué
avant la musique des courriers aux
locaux s'est ouvert au sénat
voilà ont profité moi je suis très très
très très contente d'être ici
aujourd'hui parce que ça fait deltell
qui confie pas le cancer gay
aujourd'hui je suis là en plus c'est
d'image donc je suis très très heureuse
et le festival rio loco à toulouse c'est
jusqu'à ce dimanche avec une
programmation riche en musique et en
artiste star lui c'est une star mondiale
connue de tous les continents pour sa
carrière exceptionnelle alain delon fait
son retour dans les médias et à la
télévision
silencieux depuis son avc il y a deux
ans l'acteur iconique prendra la parole
le 1er juillet prochain sur tv5 monde
pour un entretien exclusif que j'ai eu
la chance de mener pendant plus d'une
heure chez lui bonjour alain delon
bonjour suivent alain delon l'acteur
français évoquera évidemment l'actualité
du moment le coronavirus la vaccination
joe biden ou encore le sujet sur
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
ces souvenirs de cinéma son désir de
tournage seront également au menu de cet
entretien tout à fait exclusif alain
delon évoquera enfin sa passion des
territoires vous pourrez aussi découvrir
un bout de cette interview dans un
prochain grand jt des territoires pour
voir là ne l'ont face au monde rendez
vous jeudi 1er juillet à 21h sur tv5
monde
en france nous en parlions au tout début
de cette édition la pollution
atmosphérique est devenu depuis quelques
années un enjeu majeur public pour
rendre nos déplacements plus propre
l'électrique est aujourd'hui privilégiée
sur nos routes mais aussi dans les airs
à brest par exemple le velisek trop à un
premier avion 100 % électrique vient de
faire son entrée au sein de l'aéro club
local son autonomie de vol et de 1h une
découverte aérienne et écolo de louis
floch de la rédaction de tébéo
lhm du groupe le télégramme en bretagne
c'est une première mondiale et ça se
passe à brest depuis quelques jours
l'aéro club de brest finistère accueille
le premier aéronef électrique certifié
par l' agence européenne de la sécurité
aérienne baptisée velis électro ce petit
biplace qui ne pèse que 600 kg est en
location auprès de la société brestoise
green aéro lise c'est un avion pour les
aéro club à la base sur les écoles de
formations pour former les pilotes pour
faire des baptêmes pour découvrir
l'aérien l'aérien électrique décarbonés
une heure d'autonomie et avoir le
plaisir de voler sans bruit le velly ce
électro et conçu par l'entreprise
pipistrelles aircraft basé en slovénie
il est aussi le 11e avions de l'aéro
club de brest finistère dans le club
ça fait une dizaine d'années qu'on
réfléchisse la problématique de la
consommation de l'écologie du bruit et
on a renouvelé durant cette dizaine
d'années 70% notre flotte sur ces
aspects là l'avion électrique c'est la
suite logique de tout ça à bord la
stabilité remarquable l'absence de bruit
déconcertante à l'avenir green a rôles
il espère multiplier et allonger ses
trajets
d'abord pour les entreprises puis dans
quelques années pour les particuliers
dans deux ans on aura des avions de
transport qui permettront aux pme de se
déplacer partout en france et en europe
c'est une dynamique qui ceux qui se
lancent et qui va permettre à nos
territoires à nos entreprises de se
développer en région et créer des
emplois en région
demain samedi le parking p3 de
l'aéroport sera gratuit toute la journée
environ deux mille visiteurs sont
attendus pour découvrir ce nouvel oiseau
électrique qui compte bien continuer de
grandir reste en abordant ce grand jt
des territoires pour découvrir à présent
un studio de tournage
unique en son genre à toulouse celui ci
met notamment à disposition des
professionnels un décor d'avion à taille
réelle 500 m² au total et stéphanie
forgeois il ya posé sa caméra pour vyas
occitanie regarder
l'agglomération toulousaine investi dans
le cinéma c'est à coulommiers que le
studio de tournage le grand cet âge
ouvert ses portes en mai 2020 avec ses
1200 mètres car il s'agit d'un concept
inédit en europe
à l'intérieur on retrouve un décor
d'avion modulable de 500 mètres carrés
qui s'adapte à toutes les scènes à bord
on a décidé de faire un studio de cinéma
dans les règles de l'art avec les prises
de son parfaite avec la lumière un pont
lumière qui descend tout ce qu'il faut
pour pouvoir tourner un long-métrage est
inspiré des airbus une dizaine de
personnes ont travaillé sur la maquette
pour la dessiner et la construire on
peut passer une caméra qui sort de
l'avion qui passe à travers l'avion et
qui ressort de l'autre côté on peut
faire des des travellings où on enlève
les plafonds avec un travail de vue de
dessus le directeur de master film
espère tourner une centaine de jours par
an dans son studio
son atout principal reste le décor
d'avion mais pas que voilà c'est un
studio qui est dédié ou tournage mais
pas forcément tournage aéronautique on a
un atelier de décoration peut créer à
l'appartement on peut créer tout type
site c'est un studio de tournage
un voyage qui ne fait que commencer pour
le grand 7 le studio veut amplifier
l'expérience de l'avion et construit
actuellement un cockpit un nouvel envol
prêt pour début 2011 22
dans le reste de l'actualité les
épreuves du baccalauréat ont débuté
cette semaine avec la très redoutée
épreuve écrite de philosophie lundi
c'est le grand oral qui commencera pour
les élèves de terminale un moment
évidemment particulier et très stressant
c'est la première fois que cet oral est
organisée qui plus est dans un contexte
marqué par le coronavirus pour aider et
soutenir les élèves les lycées ont
organisé des sessions de préparation
comme dans cet établissement de
seine-maritime vous allez voir une aide
utile avant le jour propos recueillis
par clément soyez de la chaîne normande
regarder je me sens très stressée par la
voix grave parce qu'ils essaient ainsi
le premier oral qu'on va passer donc la
première les premières vraies épreuves
des bacs pourra passer avec les la philo
au début c'était très craintif il ne
voyait pas bien en quoi ça consiste et
cela leur faisait peur puis au fur et à
mesure une fois que la question a été
trouvé une fois qu'ils ont bien
travaillé sur leur réponse
là ils se sentent plus confiants ils
arrivent à se détacher de ce cette
épreuve qui faisait peur il commence à
se sentir plus à l'aise
l'économie dans nos régions à présent
avec vous michel picot bonjour michel
vous allez nous parler aujourd'hui de la
médecine mais de la médecine du futur et
à lyon bonjour sert il bonjour à tous
imaginez je ne vous le souhaite pas bien
sûr mais vous êtes victime d'une
fracture qui nécessite une chirurgie qui
peut être lourde mais cela permettra la
reconstitution de votre os brisés cette
reconstruction de l'os humain peut
prendre beaucoup de temps et être
douloureuse et c'est là que l'entreprise
lyonnaise en fait de villeurbanne qui
s'appellent norah coeur a inventé le
vert bio actifs de synthèse se composait
permet de réparer en hausse et stimule
ce dernier à fabriquer de la matière
osseuse
le verbe bioactifs se résorbe lui au fur
et à mesure que l'osmose se régénère
attention ce matériau est injectée sous
forme de liquide ou implantées sous
forme de granulés à l'intérieur de ce
produit par don auprès du corps médical
mais je vais faire très simple on y
trouve du calcium du sodium et du
silicium mélangés avec des morceaux d'os
du patient c'est une préparation
extrêmement minutieuse dont seuls n'aura
coeur le savoir faire aujourd'hui
les produits développés par l'entreprise
sont des dispositifs médicaux
implantables de classe 3 qui répondent
aux exigences européennes
leurs solutions sont utilisées par
exemple pour une opération d'une hernie
discale
un problème au genou et même en
chirurgie dentaire et les applications
sont immenses l'innovation s'exporte
aujourd'hui dans plus de 100 pays dans
le monde et on n'a pas fini d'entendre
parler de nora coeur dans la médecine de
demain
médecine de demain qui est déjà une
réalité aujourd'hui voilà merci michel
picaud on vous retrouve dans une
prochaine édition du grand jt des
territoires sans transition intéressons
nous maintenant à un label peu connu ami
des bébés c'est son nom à la belle rare
que seules certaines maternités peuvent
se vanter d'avoir c'est le cas notamment
depuis décembre dernier de l'hôpital le
corbusier dans la loire alors que veut
dire précisément ce label pour les
mamans et surtout aussi pour les
nouveautés
réponse avec adrien laiterie pour tl7 la
télévision de la loire c'est à l'interné
plutôt le petit mano et à deux jours
c'est le deuxième enfant pour marie mais
c'est la première fois qu'elle accouche
hills
c'est quand même hyper familiale c'est
vrai que c'est pas un grand grand
hôpital
donc on a vraiment la préhension
vraiment très écoutée on sent vraiment
qu'on s'occupe bien nous conte et qu'on
est vraiment très entourées quoi le
label s'appuie sur trois principes un
environnement rassurant pour les
familles un esprit d'équipé au sein du
personnel et le respect des besoins de
la maman et du nouveau né
l'objectif c'est de se renouveler et de
sortir des sentiers battus de sortir du
fait qu'on accouche forcément les jambes
un opposition green écologique
la maman elle-même elle sait comment
elle peut se positionner
il ya donc plusieurs accessoires pour
aider l'accouchement mais il y en a
aussi pour le préparer
quelques heures avant la naissance la
salle nature est à disposition des
mamans on y trouve une baignoire adapté
des lianes de suspension des ballons de
mobilisation du matériel pour
accompagner les mamans et les papas car
eux aussi peuvent être largement
présents 1 on propose à chaque pas pas
de rester une nuit deux nuits trois
nuits au contact de sa femme et de son
bébé s'il le souhaite autre
particularité avec ce label c'est
l'utilisation du pot à pau le but est de
proposer à toutes les mamans de prendre
leur bébé contre leur peau après la
naissance pendant au moins une heure
cette technique permet aux nouveaux nés
de sentir l'odeur de ses parents et de
l'habituer à son nouvel environnement
on sert n'aperçoit beaucoup par rapport
aux mamans aussi qui ont déjà plusieurs
enfants et qui en revenant nous disent
mais ça a vraiment changé dans votre
accompagnement on ressent vraiment le
changement et c'est positif oui il
faudra l'entretenir toute cette qualité
au service maternité car le label est
attribué seulement pendant quatre ans
avant de pouvoir être renouvelé
et puis la période des foins a aussi
débuté dans nos campagnes agriculteurs
et producteurs ont profité ces derniers
jours du beau temps pour faucher l'herbe
et faire des boules de foin
celles ci serviront à nourrir le bétail
l'hiver prochain bien sûr et bonne
nouvelle cette année la récolte est
abondante et de qualité comme ont pu le
constater ludovic bizia et hélène le
plat pour vosges télévision depuis
quelques jours et pour encore quelques
heures seulement avant le retour de la
pluie les tracteurs sont de sortie aux
quatre coins du département
sur ces images ce mardi sur les hauteurs
du thillot ici ac les antennes au nord
de rambervillers on parle bien sûr de la
coupe et de l'ensilage d'herbe pour
nourrir les animaux l'hiver prochain
jean louis et les quatre autres associés
de l'exploitation familiale ont fauché
ces derniers jours quelque 60 hectares
et cette année les rendements seront
exceptionnelles un tiers de plus
qu'habituellement je suis sûr que là on
a 35 % de matière sèche ce qui est le
stade optimum pour ans il est pour
conserver toutes les valeurs nutritives
de l'herbe et ne met que le si l'eau ne
coule pas dans qui aura aucune perte
aucune perte aussi l'eau
ce silo le voici un silo horizontal qui
sera rempli à ras-bord l'opération
consiste à optimiser la quantité d'herbe
stockées en la répartissant et en la
taxant de l'herbe qui sera mangée par
une bonne partie des 700 animaux de
l'exploitation pour quasi un an puisque
on met aux vaches laitières on met à 8 à
10 kilos d'ensilage d'herbe par jour aux
vaches necker elle et orion en ont sept
à huit kilos en un an sillage de qualité
et en quantité de bonne augure après
deux années où les exploitations
agricoles ont souffert de la sécheresse
ça va nous permettre de pouvoir refaire
un petit peu de stock est de
d'appréhender l'avenir un peu plus
sereinement les prochaines votations
d'engins agricoles dans les parcelles
concerneront les céréales des moissons
qui s'annonce elle aussi satisfaisante
à moins d'un coup de chaud à plus de 30
degrés fin juin quand le blé et honfleur
c'est un métier essentiel dans les
campagnes et pourtant le manque de
professionnels commence à préoccuper les
autorités
les vétérinaires ruraux peine à être
recrutés en corse notamment le métier
risque de disparaître totalement et
l'activité est évidemment bien
différente de celle des cabinets en
ville c'est pourquoi la rédaction de
corse matin s'est intéressé dans son
quotidien aemq bernard vétérinaire rural
depuis plus de 20 ans sur l'île de
beauté
regardez dans le rural
les vétérinaires se déplace à domicile
pour s'occuper des troupeaux en corse
ils ne sont plus qu'une petite vingtaine
à prendre la route chaque jour comme
aymeric bénard qui officie sur la région
ajaccienne
le travail ne manque pas et est
essentiel pour les éleveurs si vous
pouvez pas déplacer seulement bénin
au fond ce que l'on connaît tout le
moins on sait combien ces conférences
aussi fait avec les deux sens sur 50
brebis les béliers s'il est suivi de
l'est suivi obligatoire annuelle
on cherche des bruxelloises et notamment
qu'une maladie transmissible à l'homme
et on surveille ça je manquais pas de
brucellose dans les troupeaux pour
passer de contamination possible avec le
lait ou le fromage parfois le praticien
doit aussi faire face à des imprévus
avant de reprendre la route n'attend
qu'à être là on en profite
souci sur la jument il assure un rôle de
conseil auprès des propriétaires et de
formation avec les apprentis ça apporte
de la pratique déjà chose qu'on ne fait
pas pendant les trois premières années à
l'école et aussi de se confronter un peu
à la réalité parce que on a bola nous
l'enseigné mais rien ne vaut la réalité
du terrain le nombre de vétérinaires
augmente dans l'île mais la plupart
s'installent en clinique et se
spécialise dans le cannet où le félin
une facette du métier qui demande moins
de contraintes
les vétérinaires de campagne eux sont de
moins en moins nombreux dans une région
où le rural pourtant représente une part
importante de l'économie
voilà nous perçons de la terre à l'eau
dans ce grand jt des territoires mais
nous restons en corse pour découvrir une
activité étonnante la coiffe capping le
principe est assez simple fabriquer des
décors naturels pour aquarium encore une
société vient de se lancer dans ce
secteur et propose même des stages pour
les passionnés kevin pas nizzoli est à
quoi ce cas peur il évoque son activité
à clara mar les journalistes avia
télévisée la cua scalping c'est l'art de
décorer à l'aquarium en recréant un
décor naturel mais sous l'eau ça existe
depuis un peu plus d'une vingtaine
d'années et moi je me suis découvert
cette passion l'année dernière pendant
le confinement je me suis offert un
petit aquarium de là je me suis
renseigné un peu sur les réseaux sociaux
pour essayer de faire quelque chose d'un
petit peu sympathique et j'ai découvert
ce monde un peu extraordinaire 100 % de
nos produits sont naturels donc aucun
plastique aucune résine
on va essayer de faire avec tout ce
qu'on trouve dans la nature des pierres
du bourg à des plantes du sable pour
recréer ce monde
justement sous marins ce week-end
partout en europe se déroulent les
journées de l'archéologie de nombreuses
villes participent à cette 12e édition
l'objectif c'est de sensibiliser le
public à la diversité de notre
patrimoine à limoges vous allez voir les
animateurs du service ville d'art et
d'histoire accompagné d'archéologues
entraîne des écoliers dans le quartier
médiéval de la boucherie il persiste
ainsi les mystères des maisons à pans de
bois
alain drouho pour la chaîne cette à
limoges s'est rendu sur place et a
effectué la visite avec le regard des
près de 8000 scolaire je pense les rues
de limoges avec le service ville d'art
et d'histoire chaque année il ya un
petit plus aujourd'hui à l'occasion des
journées européennes de l'archéologie
avec la présence d'archéologues tous
ensemble vont tenter de percer les
mystères du quartier de la bouche c'est
ce qui est exceptionnel cette année
c'est la collaboration avec avec un
hiver autour de ce qu'on appelle un pc
est un projet collectif des recherches
autour du bois et la thématique de ces
journées là c'est le bois pour ça qu'on
est aujourd'hui dans le quartier de la
boucherie qu'une première animation
permet de découvrir les techniques de
datation du bois et raconte comment te
faire parler qu'ils des poutres en bois
mais pour raconter la vie d'un arbre et
raconter quand il bat les connaissances
actuelles datent les constructions des
13ème et 14ème siècle
une position qui pourrait évoluer un peu
plus loin les écoliers sont déjà dans la
pratique élèves qui sont très intéressés
par l'histoire
découvrent leur ville l'architecturé
c'est vrai que la ville de limoges avec
ses ateliers
tu l'as dans le nous permet justement de
venir sur le terrain de découvre avec
ces parfaits au 14e les bâtisseurs
maîtrisaient le recyclage en faisant les
analyses d'andreu chronologique en
faisant des datations aussi fine que
possible on arrive en tout cas à
restituer l'évolution générale du
bâtiment voir adapté assez précisément
certaines modifications visites
thématiques sont proposées tout au long
de l'année
et on termine ce grand jt des
territoires avec des travaux et des
images exceptionnelles en provenance du
mans dans la sarthe
il concerne l'église de la couture un
bâtiment classé aux monuments
historiques en plein centre ville
après la restauration de la charpente
c'est actuellement la toiture qui est
rénové un chantier unique avec un
reportage à 50 mètres de hauteur vous
allez voir de la le panorama est
saisissant anthony python pour vient
lmtv sarthe s'est rendu là haut
notamment regarder
[Musique]
ce sont des travaux d'urgence qui ont
commencé la toiture de l'église la
couture est en cours de restauration
suite à des infiltrations d'eau gardois
se compose on laisse souvent une petite
trace derrière ou un bout de papier et
puis comme ça ceux qui découvriront plus
tard environ en quelle année on a fait
la couverture
une façon de rentrer dans la grande
histoire pour alexis l'édifice a été
construit entre le 11e et le xvème
siècle et est classé monument historique
les ardoises qu'on est en train de poser
là on la pose exactement comme elle
était avant
au clos alors on a fait quelques petites
modifications techniques qui consistait
à mettre des ardoises copine parce que
l'artois ce qu'on finma va épouser
complètement la courbe et du coup elle
va pas se soulever quand il ya du vent
objectif préserver le patrimoine mais
aussi le valoriser pour le faire
découvrir au public dès l'année
prochaine
un guide conférencier assurera des
visites toutes les charpentes sont
restés finalement en l'état non
transformé depuis les différentes phases
de réalisation de l'église on a vraiment
des charpentes qui correspondent aux
différents différentes périodes de
construction d'extension ou de
reconstruction de l'église abbatiale de
la couture après le clocher d'autres
parties de l'église seront aussi rénovés
maintenant on va engager un plan
pluriannuel donc sur plusieurs années
pour
peu à peu refaire les toitures les
toitures de l'église on a par ailleurs
aussi un hacker de m
le patrimoine le rendre accessible
préserver donc au sein même de l'église
et la couture on va faire des
rénovations sont des havres la fin des
travaux du clocher est attendu pour la
fin de l'année 2022 coût de l'opération
2 180 mille euros voilà c'est la fin de
ce long j'étais des territoires merci de
l'avoir suivi sur nos chaînes locales et
régionales et sur tv5 monde
on se retrouve très vite pour un tour
complet de l'actualité de nos
territoires
et n'oubliez pas aller voter ce week-end
au revoir à tous
[Musique]